the One Piece manga just made it clear
that Admiral kizaru is going to be a
massive problem for Luffy because in
this chapter we get to see a glimpse of
the light man's truly incredible Powers
as he not only sends Luffy flying but
also easily destroys this giant robot
and brushes aside jewelry Pawnee like
she's basically somebody and on top of
that the insane former warlord Kuma is
running wild in marijua and in his first
major action since the time skip the
fleet Admiral Aquino is coming to stop
him which honestly I'm just super
excited about this as well because it
could mean that Kuma might soon be
revealing some of the world government's
darkest secrets to the one Marine who
has the power and the ruthlessness let's
be real to take out the world Nobles and
if this wasn't enough this chapter also
revealed a truly mind-blowing secret
about the one-piece treasure and that's
because Luffy's literal heartbeat
appears to have awakened this gigantic
ancient robot which could be the
explanation for why Roger couldn't use
what he found on love tail why Shanks
stole the Nika devil fruit and also why
Shanks is only now ready to actually go
after the one piece but let's kick off
things with the most heart pounding
action we've had in what feels like
quite a few chapters and that's because
kizaru is clearly not holding back at
all even though we do continue to get
brief flashbacks about all the memories
that he actually shared with Dr vegapunk
which just makes him seem even more like
a pretty good dude who's friends with a
lot of those people like sento model
Bonnie and even Kuma and really at this
point I'm generally worried that this
whole situation is gonna end with a
truly heartbreaking scene where kizaru
is forced to kill one of his longtime
friends which honestly I originally
didn't quite believe what actually
happened but now that Oda is pulling in
our heartstrings with all of these
wholesome moments like weirdly wholesome
seems like he's really setting us up for
some sort of really tragic ending here
for someone I mean either that or maybe
Kizer will just suddenly realize that he
doesn't actually just have to blindly
follow orders like a government slave
which is a pretty fitting parallel to
Kuma who was literally turned into a
Mindless government slave but more on
him in just a moment because first we're
gonna have to talk about how true truly
incredible kizaru's Powers actually are
I mean honestly it's always been a
little bit disappointing that he doesn't
exactly move as fast as our real world
Lightspeed but wow I mean this chapter
really finally gave me some of that
breathtaking speed that I've really
always wanted to see from him because
when he zoomed away from eckhead Island
only to fly back in and absolutely Crush
gear for Luffy my own eyes popped out of
my head a bit as well honestly which
makes this all the more impressive
because he did this to Snake Man Luffy
which you know arguably is Luffy's
fastest four and maybe besides gear 5
and arguably even faster however I'm not
quite buying that kizaru is stronger
than Luffy quite yet because we've seen
many times before where our character
looks super strong and competent for
like a chapter or two only for them to
just get completely wiped out just a
short time later I mean if you remember
even the cp0 agent Lucci looked quite
decent in his fight against Luffy here
on echid island but then Luffy quickly
considered him no threat at all just a
little while later and this is
especially true at the end of the
chapter apparently where we see a giant
gear 5 Luffy reach down and grab kizalu
it's like he's some sort of child's toy
so this fight definitely has a way to go
unless of course it gets interrupted by
I don't know like a giant ancient robot
or something along those lines
come on I have to be completely honest
that when I saw this thing waking up
because of Luffy's gear 5 heartbeat
apparently my mind instantly went into
like super Theory overdrive if you know
what I mean like we have gear 5 Joy boy
the drums of Liberation this giant
elephant that can also hear that
heartbeat the Eternal frame Roger Shanks
the one piece I mean
there is so much kind of seemingly
related to this but okay let's slow down
and actually break down what we know
here like first of all in chapter 1067
which is already quite a while ago we're
told that this armored giant here was
actually made over 900 years ago so
clearly it's something from the
technologically advanced ancient Kingdom
which does make me wonder why exactly
would it wake up in response to Luffy's
heartbeat well unless this is just some
sort of clever trick that oda's playing
on us then the answer should clearly be
that it can hear the drums of Liberation
just like the elephant zunisha could
when Luffy first awakened in wano and
now we obviously don't really know how
that exactly would be possible but we
should be able to assume that somehow
The Joy boy who was alive during the
void Century somehow also made it so
that this thing responded to his own
personal heartbeat which means now that
Luffy also has the same heartbeat when
he enters gear 5. this thing is waking
up to possibly fulfill its own ancient
Mission kind of similar to zunisha you
know unless of course I guess it's
waking up to attack Luffy which honestly
would be hilarious but I kind of still
doubt it though I can't wait to see what
crazy Powers this could actually have
because vegapunk also told us that this
thing attacked marijua 200 years ago but
then ran out of power before it could
actually finish its job but you know
actually brings up a couple of really
interesting questions like where did it
come from are there more of these things
and maybe most importantly how it
awakened at all 200 years ago like was
there another Joy boy 200 years ago with
Luffy's devil fruit or did it have some
alternative power source that it can use
as well and speaking of power sources
this brings us to another theory which
actually got a lot more evidence in this
chapter which is that Luffy's gear 5
Awakening might actually be related or
even the so-called eternal flame that
the Lilith version of vegapunk mentioned
in chapter 1065. and in case you don't
remember this was first introduced
during a discussion about fuel sources
and the list saying that you would love
to make her very own Sun for energy so
you see how this is connected yet so
basically somehow Luffy's gear 5
Awakening will allow him to use his
devil fruit to somehow create his own
energy I mean his devil fruit is named
after the ancient figure Nika who is
often referred to as the sun gods and so
I'm kind of thinking now that Luffy will
literally make his own sun which can
power all of the other ancient
technology because keep in mind that the
vegapunks have actually made a somewhat
similar fuel source called the mother
flame which was actually used to destroy
this entire Island but it does seem to
be limited and can only be made by
vegapunk on eckhead Islands however
there is still quite a lot that we
really just don't know and I also wonder
why this giant robot didn't wake up when
Luffy was using gear 5 earlier during
his fight with so cheap and can you just
imagine the possibility of Luffy
actually Awakening a ton of just ancient
technology and uh speaking of just that
this could also be one of the very first
major clues for why Roger couldn't
actually use whatever he found on love
tail all those years ago because we do
know that his Vice Captain Rayleigh said
that they were way too early to use what
they found there so perhaps they
actually needed a joy boy or his powers
to awaken so that his heartbeat could
kind of power whatever is waiting on the
island and actually I think it makes
even more sense when you consider that
it was only after Shang saw that Luffy
had awakened gear 5 that he finally
decided to go after the one piece so
maybe Roger told him or somehow he
figured out that he needed someone to
awaken Luffy's devil fruit before the
one piece treasure could actually be
found and used which now I know makes it
kind of sound like Shanks is only using
Luffy but hey there's already plenty of
evil Shanks theories out there so I'm
not gonna feed that particular strain I
do think he cares for Luffy on a certain
level which now brings us to the final
world shattering part of this chapter
where Kuma is going absolutely berserk
in the holy land marijua and clearly he
has some sort of mission here whether he
was given orders by the leader of the
Revolutionary Army dragon or by vegapunk
or he's just going there on his own
accord we don't really know although
probably isn't Dragon let's be honest
since he was really surprised back in
chapter 1067 when Kuma very suddenly
left the revolutionaries and vegapunk
also doesn't seem like he would order
him to cause destruction so maybe it's
just his own last desire or plan which
means that we have to ask ourselves what
his actual purpose is here I mean it
doesn't really seem like a big enough
goal just to kill some Celestial Dragon
so if we're thinking bigger could it be
that his true goal here is to expose
some of the deep dark secrets hidden on
marijua specifically I'm of course
talking about the sacred rule of the
world emu or maybe one of the National
Treasures hidden deep within the castle
maybe something like a you know giant
straw hats and there's literally no
better person for this kind of mission
than the man with the very overpowered
devil fruit that can basically teleport
himself and other things so I guess you
could be asking why he didn't just use
that to teleport himself up the red line
but you know we'll leave that aside so
could this be the moment where emu or
the National Treasure is finally exposed
and if it is I mean my God there is no
better person to actually witness this
than the fleet Admiral Akino himself so
can we just give this man a small round
of applause because it's the very first
time that this man actually got to leave
his desk for the very first time ever
since the time skip so good job Akainu
but all jokes aside this man still packs
a quite devastating punch he easily
melts parts of Kuma's body although he
could not quite stop Kuma from actually
getting away which is impressive but
besides the fighting we do need to ask
why Oda chose this moment particularly
to bring a kind of out to play because
honestly akinu has always been one of
the most interesting characters in the
story I mean clearly he has a very very
strong sense of justice
if it's maybe a tad extreme but we do
have to ask what someone like a kind
would actually do if he found out that
the world government that he's been
always defending his entire life
actually turned out to just be a puppet
all along I mean would he just keep
following orders or would he turn
against the celestial dragons and emu I
don't really know what the answer is but
there's no other more perfect time or
situation for a kainu's world view to be
challenged then right now right here
which of course means that very soon we
could get the simply mind-blowing
possibility of a kainu fighting against
the world Nobles and this is just such
an insane idea that I actually made an
entire video explaining how akino's
Journey would have turned out to be
possibly if he had been a pirate which
you can watch right here thanks for
watching and I will see you in the next
one